bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono a pari j
oggi domenica andiamo avanti con happy
wyss e da un secolo che non faccio un
episodio di è più il drago scusatemi
veramente tantissimo ma non mi dicono
neanche perché l'ultimo assi perché
avevo mal di gola
avevo registrato l'ultima puntata di
john e il giorno dopo non avevo più voce
ovviamente piuttosto ragazze un video
non è uscito bene preferisco non
caricarlo perché veramente ci tengo che
i miei video non abbiano alcun tipo di
mancanza in generale va beh ci siamo
divulgati già troppo di beni iniziare
questa puntata di happy with vi voglio
soltanto dire adesso fatemi scegliere un
livello così almeno la finisco con
questa premessa interminabile impossible
angelo col primo e postivo della
giornata creed i ragazzi amo con steve è
steve come al solito come ogni domenica
ci dicono che è impossibile ma noi ce la
faremo
vai con le mie ok perfetto come non
detto perché non c'è l'audio come si
mette l'audio ok perfetto
ripartiamo un attimo perché non c'era
l'audio senza l'audio ovviamente no io
estivo non riusciamo a concentrarci
adesso ce la facciamo vero steve ok
questo era di allenamento andiamo con la
prossima anche questa di allenamento ci
vogliono sempre tre tentativi poi ci
riusciamo
ok ragazzi sono voglio provare a fare
oddio oddio oddio che cosa etica che
cosa etica una donna
la donna che vito no questo ragazzo
replay
[Musica]
è stata la cosa più epica di sempre non
penso riuscirò mai a fare una cosa del
genere di nuovo direi riprovare raga
magic sword trovavo il primo ok ma
questo non è uno sport troppo c'è ed è
di contro è di senza casco il vero è di
a quello col casco brutto stronzo sei un
fake
ok mi sono ci sono solo come un idiota
riprova è che cazzo cos'è e perché è una
spalla indemoniata ma per addio che cosa
ho io che cosa horror maraga ma che
cazzo di livello è c'è una spada
indemoniata cosa
[Musica]
anche tornata in mano fantastico suo
livello ha un non so che di epico però
non l'ho capito direi di cambiare subito
glass rider e ora gal conoscevo soltanto
ghost rider più che altro c'è stiamo con
luke e il padre ci sono delle coop dio
mine share ma che cazzo di senso o dio e
scafato jeff beck
ci sono tanti in ogni ciak arrivano
prima io del jack black
ho vinto e stata una cosa molto non
senso c'è questo non l'ho capito come
livello vabbè battaglia a mezz'aria
questa mi ispira un casino
dovevo caricarlo meglio raga allora ci
siamo ok io no mi sono infilato subito
in partenza merda
cos'è ti prendo dati stacco la gamba
sembra una nuova versione del kamasutra
meloni e scorse di zucca è una roba
molto scena però è bene direi di avviare
livello è stata una cosa veramente
nonsense saga prova di avviare anche
incazzo
ma non riesco a tenere poi capitanata ma
sono infilzato da due parti c'è anche il
melone contro di me merda sono che cazzo
niente raga non ci vedevo riprovarci
perché non posso crederci non riuscirà a
maneggiare una cazzo di spada
riproviamoci baietti setti vai così no
perché è di per sé
bravo intera china che cazzo di senso
alto livello
direi ricambiare livello raga è una cosa
veramente assurda
andiamo su rock swing king sono re dei
dei rock swing si vai con è di nuovo
file non te la cavi tanto con le spade
ma coi lupi swing ce la fai
ok vai grandissima e di vai senza gamba
prendi la scarpa che ti serve prendi a
scarpa brutto stronzo che cazzo ok vai a
tieni sulla gamba che bravo merda devo
riuscire ragazze sentite comunque alto
il microfono la profitto le video di
happy wings che tra poco lo devo
cambiare e microfono perché quando urlo
come un pazzo maniaco si sente che dà
fastidio quindi ho deciso di cambiarlo
quindi tra poco per la gioia delle
vostre orecchie cambierò microfono
finita la premessa mi si sono spezzate
le braccia come faccio no ce n'è ancora
uno di braccio allora vai con un braccio
niente neanche quello dai che ho vinto
dai sono volto un secondo dopo aver
vinto the city nights of the seas gin
and it or sono i dari che cosa sia cioè
a fottio che cazzo
è diverso stessi lei toccherà a questo
che cazzo
ok va bene noi andiamo ai design e miss
l'ater my name l'ater e fammi leggere
niente niente niente the way scale c'è
solo una via per scappare devo seguire
la lucina raga che si chiama l'ater mai
perfetto l'ater devo seguire che cazzo è
ok
devo seguire la luce ma che cazzo
succede a devo scrivere la roba che mi
cade dal cielo ma ditelo che ne so io
vabbè eri arrivo di un a quel punto raga
ci sono di nuovo devo schivare sta roba
perfetto e ditelo prima che ne so io ma
la lucina che cazzo serve a niente merda
merda merda che culo mi ha tagliato solo
il bene ma sono ancora vivo
wow grazie devo riuscire a checa no
merda è di con lo smoking non l'avevo
mai visto liz hurley si è molto brutto
sì ma io sono più bello sono più belle
quindi riesco a schivare le sue ma
perché fa così ci sembra veramente la
ruota di quelle delle giostre cioè non
ha senso
you are doing it great grazie a questo
li odio cos'è che figo devo saltare le
cose fa basso livello e una cosa assurda
se non ho mai giocato un platform ok no
merda non riesco a salta un gradino è di
cazzo è di deve esaltare una merda di
gradino ed perché perché vi do riesce a
saltare un gradino perché ti sei fatto
[ __ ] da un gradino di merda perché è
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo il primo
gradino è andato michael ii vai ed i
brutti niente dai non ci posso credere
se ce l'ha fatta sono riuscito a saltare
un gradino di merda non ci posso credere
la sfida più incredibile del mondo ok ci
sono più gradini la cosa diventa
complicata merda non riuscivo a saltarne
1 prima devo saltarmi così tanti sì no
no ma chi cazzo ma perché
è scattata ira dei gradini sono miei
nemici non ce la faccio cambio livello
raga perché questa è una cosa assurda
andiamo con portal non so che cos'è ma
uso andiamo con nonno ciak è quindi
siamo dio che salto assurdo
devo riuscire a tipo norme ok mi sono
spiazzi che ha vinto ha vinto la sedia a
rotelle e io mi sono spiaccicato al muro
tipo non sono zanzara sul parabrezza
però sono ancora vivo andiamo con
forrest def foresta della morte ci sono
degli arpioni sugli alberi
ok uk dobbiamo passare inosservati fa il
piano come tu insegnato a noi hoc come
ti ho insegnato devi stare zitto
vabbè andiamo avanti da soli non abbiamo
bisogno di quel bambino di merda che ci
fa scoprire
ok [ __ ] stiva anche a te che cazzo
sondaggi nonno chuck ed il obesa ci sono
tutti a rapporto
sono diventato un killer o cosa non lo
so neanche io ok devo merda devo
superare di nuovo i gradini raga i
gradini non li sopporto in happy wings
non ci riesco sono impedito che questo
ragazzo avevo ancora incontrato amy ma
che mi devo andare avanti stai zitto
devo devo proseguire no no no no no no
una merda sono rimasto incastrato
qualcuno mi dia un calcio in culo ok
perfetto grande no no ok
raga forse riesco a tornare indietro
senza morire credo è però devo tipo
ok che cazzo
portal cos'è porta mi ispira dalle 9
perché mi ricorda porta alla punto devo
prendere tipo le moneta ok perfetto va e
che salta
no no merda ma perché sono impedito con
la bici oggi c'è ma secondo me gli occhi
che porta sfiga maledetto york ok ci
posso riuscire stavolta me lo sento
no ma perché cazzo che curò che culo
assurdo
ok ce la posso fare incredibile e rago
avuto un culo assurdo andiamo a fare uno
sguardo stavolta proviamo con chuck è ok
ciao look tutto a posto
sì in teoria doveva lanciare le spade
alla prossima perfetto
ok raganello steve è riuscito a partire
dentro vado madonna che killer killer le
spa no ok per tre spade in una madonna
raga laica boss toro mi fa una pippa qui
sì però che è rimasta penzoloni la tipa
dietro però sono morto io come non detto
quindi niente da fare ripartiamo c'è
adesso non mi interessa raga finché non
lo finiscono continuo che cazzo no
perché io perché devo riuscire a beccare
ok perfetto
rimane soltanto sti braga non ce la farò
mai a beccare steve raga troppo lontano
steve devo fare una roba
intendevo l'altro steve non the kill
your ugly wife questo livello mi ispira
dal nome c'è chi sono
ok è stata una cosa violenta da questa
non è la nutella che cazzo è stata ma
cosa senza senso
andiamo su the crazy dance suoi occhi un
perfetto ballet perfetto volevo appunto
scegliere ed i spiegami come faccio a
ballare senza gambe e vabbè andiamo lo
stesso vai
[Musica]
perfetto basta dire di cambiare perché è
di lo so che è stanco oltre extreme raga
dovevo ancora fare un boltro how in
questo episodio di è più visto come
sempre
allora siamo con eddy cioè che cazzo
perché se la mamma di uk che lo sta
puntando con un arpione cioè un buon
modo per dire vai a fare i compiti
ok poche domande andiamo avanti
cioè no merda solo partito malissimo ok
sono partito di merda praticamente devo
riuscire
ok è perfetto almeno adesso non voglio
più johnson balls perfetto allora altre
palle non fraintendete devo riuscire a
ok ho vinto questo mi sembra diciamo un
po più classico di quello di prima
se riesco a prendere la perfetta fatali
che cos'è fatality non voglio saperlo si
no merda ok dovevo aspettarmelo
sinceramente vai gwen no merda el però
non va bene almeno so riuscito un altro
help richiudete mele di nuovo ok
perfetto no ma che cazzo perfetto no ma
perché ma per sé ma che sia di merda
ragazze non ci posso credere
no ok allora ho centrato help perché
sono morto maledizione non ci posso
credere così facile arrivare alla
vittoria no non cado non cado sto
stronzo non cado non calmi porta un
pallone ce la faccio ancora
entrano di spingermi giù ma io non mollo
tra l'altro è rimasto infilzato quindi
anche se mollo rimango lì comunque va bè
ragazzi oggi non è giornata per il
vostro quindi le di fare l'ultimo
livello per oggi
find the toilet questo livello mi ispira
un casino dal nome john mayer to find a
tyler 36 mi piace un casino come come
scopo per un livello è fantastico è
fantastico anche il fatto che io mi sia
fatto schiacciare come un idiota
vaffanculò gino
riesce una se ci sono riuscito di nuovo
ragazzo ci sono riusciti se ce la sto
facendo
l'ho trovato però mi sono diciamo un po
accartocciato per così dire oggi raga
non riesco a finirne uno di livello
direi di chiudere qui raga perché
veramente c'è la voce che mi sta andando
via pian piano
ultimamente non so perché ma sono sempre
quasi sempre senza voce prima di
chiudere raga volevo soltanto
ringraziarvi tantissimo perché
ultimamente canale sta prendendo
veramente tantissimi iscritti tantissime
visualizzazioni mi piace tantissimi bei
commenti che sempre mi lasciate quindi
raga veramente grazie grazie infinite ci
stiamo avvicinando ad una velocità
allucinante al al video dei 15mila
iscritti perché veramente in un tempo
assurdo li stiamo raggiungendo quindi
raga tra poco dovrò fare anche quello
dei 15 mila iscritti e per quelli che mi
hanno chiesto qual è il nuovo episodio
horror che inizierò adesso che è finito
the grudge non ve lo dico
non me lo voglio dire raga sarà una
sorpresa anche se alcuni di voi
ovviamente l'hanno già menzionato perché
tra le miriade di cose che mi proponete
c'era anche questo però diciamo che sarà
un'esclusiva come the grudge ovvero
molti di voi non lo conosceranno quindi
preparatevi e tenetevi forte e scusate
se ho fatto questa premessa fine video
però già il video durato poco quindi un
approfittato appena possibile cercherò
di fare un episodio anche di un'ora di
penombra di è primis perché me lo state
chiedendo veramente da tantissimo tempo
appena la voce me lo permetterà diciamo
allora ho finito con la mega premessa se
vi è piaciuto video come al solito
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bella
ragazzi